euh il y a une vidéo qui fait le buzz
sur les réseaux aujourd'hui euh c'est
lors d'un trajet reliant Luton à Ibiza
Newton
c'est où ça en anglais
c'était pas en Espagne c'était quoi
votre question alors c'est où
tout simplement
Ibiza un couple a été surpris par un
steward en train de faire crac-crac
badaboum c'est mignon dans les toilettes
de l'avion regardez
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
là franchement ça c'est choquant
franchement c'est chaud quand même
c'est les consignes de sécurité
ce sont les passagers qui l'ont alerté
il y avait il y avait du bruit enfin
vous imaginez
il y avait du bruit en fait il y avait
du bruit et donc les passagers ont
commencé à s'agiter etc en comprenant
d'où ça venait ce qui se passait dans
les toilettes de l'avion le steward est
arrivé et un peu poussé par le par les
publics pour le coup bah il savait plus
s'y ouvrir pas ouvrir il a fini par
ouvrir mais il ne pensait pas qu'il
allait les trouver
parce que il sait que les gens filment
quand même c'est un professionnel il
devrait plutôt attendre le mec dans les
toilettes ou pas les deux
les deux nommés
logiquement son boulot c'est parce que
du millet des clients même si c'est pas
la raison
que vous faites quoi
s'il vous plaît alors je prends très
rarement l'avion privé un truc comme ça
[Rires]
on arrête là c'est un peu exigu mais je
me doute que quand on est dans exiguë et
je me doute que quand on a un avion
privé du coup bah voilà déjà il yaourt
ici
tout simplement voilà non non vous moi
dans le Zagreb Belgrade je me suis donné
mais c'est un train ça
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'était incroyable la fête du slip oh
non mais je m'en vends jamais quand on
parle ça donne pas une paire non plus
hein
non non non non non non
c'est lui qui a oublié
non non restez avec une meuf avec ta
meuf oui oui j'adore ça avec Fatou mais
non
tu avais les cheveux longs là quand
j'étais presque voilà il est un peu
hippie un peu débridé
sur Amsterdam on revenait et tout ça
waouh la vache
[Musique]
ni avant ni après non mais le matin les
hôtesses sont réveillés à côté de
l'autre on sait même pas regarder un mot
on a débarqué depuis tout à l'heure tu
dis les gens quelqu'un et tu sais des
hommes des femmes c'était quoi parce que
tu précises
plutôt sur les banquettes
à 5 tu as cinq sièges au milieu donc la
targement la place tu le sortais d'où
l'oseille à l'époque hein maintenant j'y
allais pour le boulot allez pour
l'arrivée du Paris-Dakar
télévision et l'autre jour
[Rires]
non mais c'est fou ça c'est fou
quelqu'un qui prend l'homme mais c'est
vrai qu'il prend son métier à cœur comme
ça c'est incroyable j'avais jamais vu ça
San Francisco Paris avec une jeune femme
une jeune Américaine qui est montée dans
l'avion et on a bu au bar parce qu'on
était en première j'étais invité aussi
c'était pour les racines et des ailes je
crois et du coup on a bu un peu des
verres au bas
et voilà et il m'a demandé pourquoi
j'avais quitté le bar j'ai parce que
j'étais jaloux parce qu'elle discutait
avec un Stewart aucune raison d'être
jaloux et bam non
il est fort hein
j'ai l'impression que les filles ont
beaucoup moins envie de réagir sur cette
séquence
elle veut pas nous parler l'autre Pascal
De La Tour-du-Pin est dans ses fiches et
Géraldine maillet elle s'est retourné
public alors The Voice
les filles n'ont pas du tout envie de
parler de ça on fait mais toi toi à mon
avis franchement pas autant que Monsieur
parce que monsieur est un recordman mais
une fois moi c'était sur un pari Bangkok
non c'est vrai je me je je le steward
c'est le Stewart le
stewarts et voilà j'ai choisi le
poisson ou viande euh non mais t'emmerde
pas que ça va et non mais c'est comment
toi comment tu la chiné de quoi tu viens
chez moi en fait non moi j'étais assis
tranquillou il m'a dit en effet poulet
poisson des mais je voyais qu'il me
regardait beaucoup il était pas mal
c'était le seul mec dans le le la bande
et puis voilà il arrêtait pas de passer
et puis quand tout le monde s'est
endormi parce que c'est les vols de nuit
tout le monde s'est endormi mais quand
voilà quand tout le monde dort bah nous
on s'est faufiler dans les toilettes de
l'avion et on a fait touche pipi
rapidement voilà et j'en suis pas fier
vraiment j'ai honte
mais j'étais jeune j'avais 23 ans 24 ans
si vous êtes consentante
[Rires]
avant celui-là c'est incroyable j'avais
juste la ceinture qui me rendait dans le
cul qui est un peu c'était pas
[Applaudissements]
c'est pour ta sécurité
c'est pour la sécurité tu sais tu veux
te dire on laisse passer franchement il
y a aucun problème avec ça il y a des
petits nouveaux et on va faire
connaissance vous pouvez pas poser la
question à Jacques à papa
un endroit un autre endroit insolite
ouais je suis très traditionnel comme la
baguette
[Rires]
moi je suis certainement passé courageux
pour faire ça pour être trop peur de me
faire avoir non jamais de la vie
mais ailleurs je sais pas moi
[Musique]
[Rires]